Die Ansage ist aber auch bei dir zu sagen, man braucht mehr, aber es ist noch ein bisschen unklar, was.
Ja, man braucht vor allem Schulung und die Lehrer brauchen Hilfe. Die Lehrer, mit denen ich gesprochen habe, waren vollkommen verzweifelt und wussten selber nicht, an wen sie sich wenden können, wenn sie Fragen haben. Und das sind dann solche Fragen wie, naja, die Schüler fragen mich, welche von diesen Chat-Applikationen, wie WhatsApp und Co.
ist mir sicher?
Wie soll ich das denn rauskriegen? Wie kann ich das bewerben?
Wer kann mir das denn sagen?
Und das sind Fragen, wo die natürlich eigentlich an der Realität von den Schülern dran sein müssten, aber selber keinen Ansprechpartner haben und alleine gelassen werden.
Na ja, vielleicht können ja sozusagen die Leute helfen, die hier noch im Studio sind. Florian, vielen Dank dir! Also große Einigkeit auf jeden Fall dafür, es muss besser werden. Und wir kommen jetzt gleich, aber jetzt wirklich gleich dazu, was denn die Projekte machen, wo die Leute heute hier im Studio sind.
Fritz Zwei Sprechstunden.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen zur zweiten Hälfte vom Chaosradio Imblemun auf Fritz, wo es heute mit Menschen aus dem Umfeld des Chaos Computer Club umfällt des Chaos Computer Clubs darum geht, wie man möglicherweise andere Menschen dafür begeistern kann, zu verstehen, wie die Technik funktioniert, die in unser Leben mittlerweile drin ist. Ich heiße herzlich willkommen noch einmal zurück, den Sebas, den Leander, die Maria, den Daniel und die Fiona. Das klingt so ein bisschen, als ob sie alle schon eingeschlafen sind, aber die sehen ein bisschen wacher aus als die anderen. Ja, wir kommen gleich dazu. Wir haben in der ersten Stunde sozusagen, es hat ein bisschen länger gedauert als eigentlich geplant, erst mal geklärt, wie es nicht funktioniert. Also was Medienkompetenz eigentlich ist, nämlich dieses grundlegende Verständnis dafür, was eigentlich die ganze Technik um unser Leben macht. Und das System, wie wir es gerade haben, noch nicht so gut damit funktioniert, wirklich alle Leute darüber zu informieren. Und die Leute, die heute hier sind, das sind Menschen von verschiedenen Unternehmungen, die wir heute mal ein bisschen vorstellen wollen. Die genau sich das zum Ziel gemacht haben. Wir fangen an mit Jugend hackt. Wer von euch übernimmt das denn jetzt? Die Maria, die gerade noch an der Flasche hängt. Wir können jederzeit damit aufhören, so lange genug das. Maria, Jugend hackt. Du bist da die Geschäftsführerin oder wie heißt das?
Nee, das heißt Projektleiterin würde ich sagen. Ich mache das aber gleichberechtigt mit Daniel, der neben mir sitzt. Und Fiona war super viel in die Orga eingebunden dieses Jahr. Und wie ich vorhin auch schon sagte, ein paar andere Leute. Vor allem viele, viele Mentoren und ehrenamtliche Helfer. Und die Idee von Jugend hackt ist eigentlich aus so einer Not geboren. Wir haben irgendwie festgestellt, es gibt Jugend musiziert, Jugend forscht. Es gibt glaube ich in Deutschland Jugend debattiert und Jugend tanzt. Und es gibt irgendwie diese ganzen Nachwuchsprogramme für junge Talente. Aber es gibt eigentlich nichts, was junge Programmiertalente fördert. Und insbesondere eigentlich diejenigen im Regen stehen lässt, die sich so im Kinderzimmer selber wissendrauf helfen. Wir nennen die so ein bisschen behelfsmäßig Kinderzimmerprogrammierer. Also all die Kinder und Jugendlichen, die sich quasi ungefragt, unangeleitet, auch völlig unabhängig von der Schule, selber die Welt hinter einem Bildschirm irgendwie erschließen. Und so ist dann die Idee entstanden, einen Jugend hackt zu machen. Also ein Förderprogramm für junge programmierbegeisterte Menschen zwischen 12 und 18.
Also ein Programmierprojekt zwischen, das kann ja alles sein, eine Webseite, wo man Programmieren lernen kann.
Nee, das ist kein Tutorial in dem Sinne, sondern das ist tatsächlich ein physisches Treffen. Wir haben das bisher jedes Jahr einmal gemacht, also 2013 begonnen, wir laden Jugendliche zwischen 12 und 18 aus ganz Deutschland für ein Wochenende nach Berlin ein und dort entwickeln sie eigenständige Software und Hardware-Produkte. Also zum Beispiel hat dieses Jahr eine Gruppe namens Awareness mit dem 3D-Drucker ein Armband ausgedruckt und darauf, ich glaube mit Python, eine Software draufgeholfen, die das Armband zum Vibrieren bringt, wann immer eine Überwachungskamera in der Nähe ist. Das war zum Beispiel eins von den ganz vielen Produkten, die an dem Wochenende entstanden sind.
Aber kommen die Leute dann an und sagen so hier, wir wollen jetzt ein Armband mit Überwachungskameras machen oder ist das eher so, da kommen Leute dann sagen, wir wollen irgendwas machen?
Ich glaube, dieses Jahr waren 120 Jugendliche da an dem Wochenende. Es kommen sicher einige schon mit einer Idee, weil die zum Teil auch zum zweiten Jahr eben schon wieder gekommen sind oder im Jahr von Jugendheit gehört haben und schon wissen, was sie erwartet. Also, dass wir ihnen nicht Aufgaben geben, sondern nur das passiert, was sie selber machen. Und ganz viele wissen, sie wollen irgendwas machen mit ihren Fähigkeiten und haben auch Bock irgendwie andere Gleichgesinnte kennenzulernen, aber wissen nicht, was. Und wir moderieren diesen Ideenprozess. Also wir helfen ihnen dabei, eine Idee zu finden, die man auch an einem Wochenende umsetzen kann. Aber was es genau ist, denken die Jugendlichen sich ganz alleine aus. Und wir haben nur so Themenvorschläge gemacht. Wir haben gesagt, hey, ihr könntet euch zum Beispiel zum Thema Überwachung Gedanken machen, was ein großes digitales Thema unserer Zeit ist. Oder ihr könnt euch zum Thema Bildung Gedanken machen. Oder im Bereich Umwelt gibt es auch, sag ich mal, kleine, gibt es Ideen, auf die man schnell kommen kann.
Wie genau läuft das ab? Also, ihr sagt, einmal im Jahr macht ihr das. Da fragt man sich natürlich, warum nicht öfter? Ist das irgendwie so aufwendig, das zu organisieren?
Es ist ziemlich aufwendig. Und vor allem sind wir halt so eine kleine, feine NGO und haben noch nicht das Bildungsministerium im Rücken, um das eben in der Breite aufziehen zu können, wie das der eine Anrufer sich eigentlich eben gewünscht hat. Also das war bisher so eine Mischung aus, wir haben nicht die Ressourcen und vor allem wollten wir auch erstmal probieren, ob es funktioniert. Also ich glaube, das ist auch das, was dem Ganzen so eigentlich den Charme gibt, habe ich so immer den Eindruck, dass wir erstmal gucken wollten, gibt es überhaupt so jungen Hackerinnen und jungen Hacker, also identifizieren, die sich mit diesem Begriff Jugend hackt oder denken die, das sind alles irgendwie die bösen Menschen, als die sie in den Medien immer dargestellt werden. Und nachdem wir jetzt zweimal so überlaufen worden sind, können wir sagen, ja, diese jungen Leute gibt es und sie haben wahnsinnig Bedarf an Förderung und Vernetzung. Aber das wollten wir erst mal rausfinden, bevor wir jetzt irgendwie riesig was aufziehen und dann irgendwie den Teilnehmern hinterherlaufen müssen, dass sie doch bitte bei uns mitmachen.
Wo kommen die denn her sozusagen? Kommen die selber zu euch ran und sagen, wir wollen da mitmachen? Oder werden die von den Eltern angemeldet?
Die allerwenigsten von den Eltern. Und dann schreiben wir auch immer eine nette Mail zurück, dass wir uns auch freuen, wenn die Kinder sich selber anmelden. Weil die sollen ja selber Interesse daran haben und teilnehmen. Und das ist ja eben keine Pflichtveranstaltung. Aber tatsächlich kommen die irgendwie so zu uns. Also die finden diese Webseite. Und dann melden die sich an und kommen aus ganz Deutschland.
Und wie läuft das dann genau ab? Also sitzt ihr dann in einer Turnhalle, wo für das Wochenende irgendwie Stühle aufgebaut wurden? Oder was passiert da?
Also es ist ein Hackathon, so vom Grundformat. Und was uns halt wichtig ist, das so anzupassen, dass wirklich die Jugendlichen selbst davor kommen. Das heißt, wir legen sehr viel Wert auf, dass die Jugendlichen erst mal ihre eigene Ideen entwickeln können und zwar gemeinsam. Also wir wollen da auch nicht, dass die Kids für sich allein programmieren. Das ist nämlich genau das, was sie von der Veranstaltung erwarten. Die sind ganz oft zu Hause und kommen dann auf die Veranstaltung und sagen sowas wie, wow ist das toll, da gibt es noch mehr, die so sind wie ich.
Ein vielgehörter Satz ist immer, endlich unter normalen Leuten.
Genau, also die wissen schon zu schätzen, ich lerne da noch mal Leute kennen, die ich vielleicht zu Hause in meinem Dorf so nicht habe in meiner Umgebung oder übers Netz oder so. Und dann fangen die an, gemeinsam Ideen zu entwickeln, kommen schon mit einzelnen Ideen, werfen die zusammen, verbessern die. Da geht schon mal viel Zeit rein. Dieses Jahr hatten wir dann auch noch Frank Rieger da, um auch genau nochmal dieses Ethikthema aufzugreifen und auch da nochmal Anschlüsse zu geben. Also wo können sie sich gesellschaftlich auch aufhängen, einbringen und so weiter. Und dann geht es schon ins Programmieren. Also sie werden begleitet von Mentoren. Das heißt, wir haben ganz viele ehrenamtliche Helfer, die verschiedenste Programmiersprachen können. Das heißt, wir versuchen da auch ein breites Feld abzudecken, um möglichst gute Unterstützung geben zu können. Und es geht aber dann wirklich um Unterstützung. Die Kids machen selber, die Jugendlichen. Und die Mentoren helfen eben an den Stellen, wo sie Infos brauchen. Oder wie strukturiere ich Code wie...
Das stellt mich schwierig vor. Ich komme jetzt dahin, so programmieren, 3D-Drucker, geil. Ethikvortrag, was... Wie packt ihr das ein, dass das klappt? Oder ist das jetzt sozusagen nur meine zynische Vorstellung von einem Menschen, die nichts über Ethik wissen wollen?
Ja, das ist tatsächlich deine zynische Vorstellung. Oh nein! Wir haben... Ja, man geht ganz optimistisch aus dem Wochenende raus. Das ist wirklich überhaupt nichts für Dystopiker. Wir haben diesen Ethiktrack irgendwie eingebaut auf Wunsch der Jugendlichen aus dem letzten Jahr. Die haben gesagt, das sei alles echt total super, aber wir würden eigentlich gerne noch viel mehr lernen und viel mehr Vortrag eigentlich bekommen. Und dann kam die Idee drauf, weil Frank Rieger, der Sprecher vom Chaos Computer Club, sowas auch unterstützt und gerne tut, den einzuladen und ihn über die Hackerethik sprechen zu lassen und tatsächlich durfte er nicht gehen. Er wurde von den Jugendlichen noch auf der Bühne belagert. Und da muss ich dich wirklich enttäuschen.
Na gut, das ist eine Enttäuschung, die ich vielleicht gerade noch so hinnehmen kann. Und sind die Ergebnisse wirklich alle so brauchbar, wie das, was ihr gerade beschrieben habt, also diese Armband, was die Verwachungskameras waren? Oder ist das auch gar nicht das Ziel, dass da was rumkommt, wo man dann sagt, ein fertiges Produkt?
Also so ein Hackerson ist natürlich so ein Stück weit produktorientiert. Das heißt, da kommen Prototypen raus, die zumindest eine großartige Idee beinhalten. Also brauchbar ist da auf jeden Fall alles, weil da haben sich ja mehrere Menschen entschieden, über ein Wochenende ein Ziel zu verfolgen und da Herzbrut reinzustecken und ihr Know-how. Und dann gibt es natürlich Awareness, dass es super kommunizierbar ist, was man dann auch öffentlich in der Presse sieht, was einfach so ein gesellschaftliches Thema aufgreift. Aber da gibt es auch andere Projekte, die sich ganz stark mit den Themen der Jugendlichen selbst beschäftigen oder Gesundheitsthemen aufgreifen, die gar nicht so schlecht besucht waren, wo wir dachten, so ja, das nehmen wir mal als Thema mit rein, weil das ist auch ein gesellschaftliches Thema. Und dann wird das mit Leben gefüllt. Also da gab es sehr viele sehr spannende. Und vor allem, es kommt halt immer von den Jugendlichen. Also da gibt es so viele schöne Ideen, auf die würden wir als Erwachsene nie kommen. Also das ist da die große Chance, einfach mal einen Freiraum zu geben. Worauf habt ihr denn Bock?
Gibt es da Kontakt zu den Erziehungsberechtigten, nenne ich sie jetzt mal? Wenn ja, was sagen die dazu? Oder was sind generell Reaktionen von anderen Leuten, die nicht konkret in dem Programm selber beteiligt waren?
Die manche Eltern bringen, gerade wenn die Kinder noch kleiner sind, die dann tatsächlich bis zu dem Veranstaltungsort nach Berlin und denen dann da so ein bisschen rum und fragen dann auch, was macht ihr denn hier? Und wir haben auch so eine FAQ-Session auf der Webseite, wo wir zum Beispiel für Eltern die Frage beantworten, kommt mein Kind irgendwie als böse Hacker aus dem Wochenende? Weil das fragen die nicht so explizit, aber die, ich würde sagen, es gibt so zwei Kategorien von Eltern, vielleicht drei, vielleicht eine Kategorie, die sich gar nicht so wirklich für die Kinder interessiert, also mit denen wir gar keinen Kontakt haben, vielleicht weil die Kinder auch einfach autonom sind so und die Eltern denen das zutrauen. Die zweite Kategorie ist wirklich dankbar, dass es Angebot gibt, dass mit ihren Kindern etwas anfangen kann, weil das natürlich meistens eher Kinder sind, die den Eltern so wissensmäßig schon lange davon galoppiert sind und sie froh sind, dass es eine Möglichkeit gibt für das Kind, auf andere Gleichgesinnte zu treffen. Und die dritte Kategorie, würde ich sagen, sind eben so die Skeptiker, die sagen, was macht ihr denn hier genau? Das sind auch die, die dann am Freitagabend, also am ersten Tag der Veranstaltung, dann immer noch so ein bisschen da rumlungern und gucken, ob das denn hier alles zu seinen rechten Gang geht und die dann das aufgegeben haben, dieses Kind irgendwie noch nach Hause zu bewegen. Also für die, das sehr gut ist, dass sie vor Ort sind, weil sie halt sehen, dass produktive Dinge passieren.
Jetzt war das irgendwie im September diesen Jahres, wann ist das nächste?
Ja, das debattieren wir gerade. Wir würden gerne für 2015 nicht mehr immer nur diese einmal im Jahr Veranstaltungen machen, weil das eben viel zu wenig ist. Und wir überlegen gerade, das in mehreren Regionen Deutschlands aufzuziehen. Und das ist natürlich auch so ein bisschen von der Geldfrage abhängig. Wie viele Sponsoren wir finden und andere Institutionen, die das bereit sind zu fördern. Denn wir versuchen schon zum Beispiel den Kindern die Reisekosten zu finanzieren. Sie müssen ja auch übernachten, also es soll schon etwas niedrigschwellig sein und nicht etwas, wo nur Kinder mit Geld eben teilnehmen können.
Ist das eben so, dass die jetzt sagen, also klar irgendwie Geld haben wir schon, ist es auch so, dass ihr Leute sucht, die sagen, ok, ich könnte mir vorstellen, das ist keine Ahnung, bei mir in der Stadt zu organisieren oder sowas. Oder ist das schon eher so, dass ihr das selber machen wollt?
Also damit steht und fällt das Ganze mit den Leuten, die die Struktur geben, die das organisieren, die da ihr Herzblut reinstecken. Und das ist schon auch ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Also man kann sowas wie Jugend hacken nicht mit Geld lösen. Also das ist ein Teil davon. Aber ein ganz wichtiger ist, das an einer Tech-NGO anzuhängen, die die gesellschaftliche Themen voran zu bringen, vorhand oder das tut, genauso am Clubumfeld anzuhängen, wo einfach engagierte Menschen sind, die da mit dem mit dem mit dem richtigen Fachwissen, aber eben auch mit der richtigen Haltung rangehen. Und letztlich dann auch nochmal die ganzen Prozesse, die da passieren. Also mit Jugendlichen arbeiten ist auch immer ein Fachgebiet. Da gehört ganz viel Didaktik, da gehört ganz viel Pädagogik dazu. Die halten wir auch nicht so hoch, aber die läuft eher so im Hintergrund. Also wie gestaltet man das? Wie kommen Jugendliche gut an? Also krasse Situation. Ich komme da allein an eine fremde Stadt und begegne 120 Menschen als 14-Jähriger. Das ist total krass. Und das irgendwie gut zu gestalten, dass den Kids da auch gut geht und dass die auch gut rausgehen, das gehört auch noch mit dazu. Ich glaube, weil das relativ gut gelungen ist, die letzten zwei Jahre waren das eben auch erfolgreiche Veranstaltungen. Und das müssen wir halt erstmal in anderen Städten auch so hinkriegen. Das heißt, da brauchen wir auf jeden Fall Partner, die Ähnliches leisten können.
Also falls ihr da Lust auf habt, wie ist die URL?
www.jugendhackt.de Kann man sich vielleicht sogar merken.
Sehr gut. Bin ja gespannt, wann das nächste Mal kommt und wie viel das dann sein wird und vor allen Dingen wo überall. Das andere Projekt, was heute auch hier ist, ist Chaos macht Schule. Also kann ich mir schon gut vorstellen, Schule und Chaos passen dann oft gut zusammen, gerade wenn der Lehrer nicht dabei ist, aber vermutlich steckt hier was anderes dahinter. Was genau macht ihr da?
Genau unser Ziel ist im Grunde genommen Medienkompetenz bei Kindern und Jugendlichen zu vermitteln. Und wir versuchen dort mit praktischen Tipps zum Schutz der eigenen Privatsphäre und dem verantwortungsvollen Umgang mit der modernen Informationsgesellschaft zu geben. Da gibt es seit dem Jahr 2006 Projekte im Chaos Computer Club, die erst durch lokale Gruppen in Hamburg und Mannheim unabhängig voneinander unter dem gleichen, zufälliger und lustigerweise unter dem gleichen Namen gestartet sind, ist das Projekt Chaos macht Schule. Und in dem Rahmen gehen wir halt in Schulen, halten dort Vorträge, allerdings nicht nur für Schüler, sondern auch für Lehrkörper und Eltern, um ein Stück weit auch Akzeptanz zu schaffen und die Angst zu nehmen, damit die auch einen Eindruck erhalten, was wir mit den Kindern im Unterricht machen.
Aber wie genau muss ich das vorstellen? Geht ihr da hin, haltet so einen zwei Stunden lang Frontal, Facebook ist böse und dann geht ihr wieder und dann ist alles gut?
Ja, so einen Vortrag halten wir meist für Eltern, so einen Frontalvortrag. Für Kinder halten wir schon einen angepassteren Vortrag, der mehr so in einem Art Workshop stattfindet, dass man mit Kindern auch mal Sicherheitseinstellungen überprüft, also an Beispielen, Profilbeispielen, die man im Vorfeld sich zusammengeklickt hat. Wir entwerfen dann ein Profil, wo wir mit ihnen in die Schule gehen und sagen, schaut mal hier mit ein paar kleinen Veränderungen an dem Profil, könnt ihr eure Privatsphäre schützen, weil soll ja nicht jeder alles über euch wissen.
Wir haben am Anfang gesagt, dass das Horrorbild entworfen ist, das es auch gibt, vom ahnungslosen Lehrkörper. Jetzt kann ich mir vorstellen, bei dieser ganzen Medienkompetenzgeschichte, dass das andere Extrem ist, Leute, die ganz selbstverständlich mit dieser Technik umgehen, also das Smartphone, die eine Blackbox in der Hose haben, und das halt irgendwie alles benutzen, aber sich halt irgendwie null dafür interessieren, was eigentlich dahinter steht. Begegnet euch sowas auch, oder ist das wieder nur mal zynischer Geist?
Nein, das ist die bittere Realität. Also sowohl als auch bei den Workshop-Veranstaltungen, die wir für die Kids machen, nehmen die Lehrer auch sehr viel mit. Man hat aber halt oft den Fall, dass Lehrer aus Klassen, die gerade beim Sport sind, oder Lehrer, die gerade frei haben, dann an solchen Veranstaltungen teilnehmen, um ihr vorhandenes Grundbissen noch mal aufzufrischen und zu festigen.
Aber es ging ja gerade um die eher andere Zielgruppe, also die Schüler oder jungen Leute, die unreflektiert damit umgehen.
Ja, die nehmen teilweise auch noch ein Stück mit. Wir haben bei einem Vortrag so ein Beispiel gehabt, der sagt, er kennt sich mit dem ganzen aus und er würde auch sein Profil zeigen und die erste Meldung, die aufpoppte, als er sich dann bei uns am Rechner einloggte, war, dass er einen Urheberrechtverschluss begangen hat, weil er Contentmaterial auf Facebook geteilt hat und das von Facebook entfernt wurde.
Ist das denn mit Wiederwillen, wie die Leute darauf reagieren, wenn ihr den Vortrag haltet, oder nehmen die das dann alles an, was ihr sagt?
Also man sieht schon, dass viele es annehmen. Also viele fühlen sich auch peinlich berührt, wenn sie das erste Mal wirklich erfahren, was sie mit den AGBs abgenickt haben und dass die Informationen, die sie dort selber angeben, auch an dritte Unternehmen weitergegeben werden und im Grunde auch nachvollzogen werden kann, was sie dort machen.
Aber das hört sich jetzt schon noch ein bisschen an, dass Chaos macht Schule, kommt sie rein und macht mir dann eigentlich das Benutzen dieser eigentlich schön bunten Sachen madig. Könnt ihr dann, oder diese Freude an der Technik, kann man die trotzdem noch vermitteln, oder geht immer nur das eine und das andere?
Ja, man muss einen gewissen Zwischenweg finden. Man muss sich halt einfach bewusst sein, Informationen, die man ins Netz stellt, die sind halt erstmal da. Also muss man im Vorfeld überlegen, welche Informationen man ins Netz stellt. Halt einfach erst denken, dann klicken. Und nicht andersrum im Nachhinein. Wir versuchen halt zu sagen, ja nutzt es, es ist da, es gehört zum Alltag ein Stück weit dazu. Aber ihr müsst halt euch auch bewusst sein, dass gewisse Gefahren auf euch zukommen. Dass die Informationen nicht nur für euch lichtbar sind, für eure Freunde, sondern auch für Dritte unbeteiligt im Zweifel. Wenn ihr nicht gewisse Einstellungen halt einfach beachtet und berücksichtigt.
Wie kommt ihr in die Schule? Geht ihr da selber hin und sagt so, hier wir wollen euch jetzt mal was erzählen? Oder kann man euch buchen? Gibt es irgendwo zu sagen, Chaos macht Schule mieten? Zum Anklicken oder wie läuft das?
Nein, man kann über die Seite des Chaos Computer Club halt sich an die Liste melden, eine E-Mail schreiben, was viele Lehrer halt auch machen. Und die erhalten dann von der jeweiligen regionalen Gruppe, die das Thema dann betreut in dem Bereich, eine Antwort. Und es ist so ein Wechselspiel. Es gibt Schulen, die auf uns zukommen und gerne hätten, dass wir vorbeikommen. Allerdings gehen wir auch gerne an Schulen, wo wir im Vorfeld selber Schüler waren und sagen, pass mal auf, wir würden hier gerne euch einen Vortrag anbieten zum Thema Datenschutz, Informationssicherheit, Umgang mit sozialen Netzwerken oder auch mal ein Lötworkshop anbieten. Die Lehrer sind auch sehr aufgeschlossen, dass fachkompetentes Personal kommt und dort Unterstützung bietet.
Das sind also die zwei Projekte, Jugend hackt und Chaos macht Schule. Ich will noch sagen, ihr macht das jetzt, Jugend hackt gab es eben erst zwei Jahre, Chaos macht Schule gibt es schon seit 2006. Habt ihr noch irgendwelche Anekdoten mitgebracht, wo sich sehr schön daran illustriert, was man in so einem Ding erleben kann? Oder geht das einfach nur sozusagen sehr gesellig und seicht vonstatten? Hier wird so geguckt und gegrinsen, das sieht für mich so aus wie, ja, aber dürfen wir das jetzt erzählen?
Ich kann den Tweet nicht, Daniel kann den besser, der mit der sexistischen Sprache bitte, den wünsche ich mir.
Muss ich noch kurz nachdenken.
Ich glaube, das ging so, dass wir haben eben, es gehört auch dazu, dass wir bei der Begrüßung aller Teilnehmer gesagt haben, so eine Sache noch, ihr kommt halt aus verschiedenen Teilen Deutschlands, das heißt, ihr sprecht halt vielleicht auch unterschiedlich und wir haben halt keinen Bock, dass ihr euch gegenseitig über eure Sprache lustig macht oder so, damit wollen wir halt unser Wochenende nicht verbringen. Und natürlich gehört dazu auch irgendwie nicht gegen Mädchen oder Jungen zu schießen, sondern ihr seid alle gleich hier. Und dann gab es offenbar irgendwo eine kleine Projektgruppe, wo der eine irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, seine Geo-Anwendung nicht zum Laufen gekriegt hat und zu seinem Rechner gesagt hat, lokalisier mich endlich, du Bitch. Und dann hat der Kumpel zu ihm gesagt, wir sollen keine sexistische Sprache benutzen, du Arschloch. Und das ist einer meiner persönlichen Lieblinge.
Da war doch irgendwie noch die Geschichte mit dem Sechsklasseadmin, die fand ich auch noch gut.
Ja, wir sind in einer Schule gewesen. Und man hatte uns zugesagt, es gibt halt einen Beamer und einen Mediatorenkoffer. Der wird dann gleich noch von jemandem gebracht. Und dann marschierte ein Sechsklässler mit einem übergroßen Koffer in den Raum rein, wo man sich fragte, ist der Koffer schwerer oder das Kind, das den Koffer trägt. Auf alle Fälle stellte sich dann während des Gesprächs mit dem Jungen heraus, dass er nicht nur diesen Koffer zusammengestellt hat, der an der Schule eingesetzt wird. Also der hat den Laptop ausgewählt, der in dem Koffer verbaut ist, den Beamer und Lautsprechersystem. Und das mit einem Lehrkörper dann zusammengeknubbert, was ich schon sehr bemerkenswert fand und auch toll. Und er erzählte dann so im Beisatz, während er den Rechner hochfuhr und sich einloggte, dass er in seiner Freizeit noch Teile des Schulnetzes halt hier administriert und halt auch so die Netzinfrastruktur und Server halt kennt.
Ich muss noch eine Anekdote zur Jugend hacktlos werden. Ich war ja auch da und ich bin ein riesiger Fan des Projektes und der ganzen Jugendlichen, die da waren. Das muss man auch nochmal echt betonen, dass eigentlich alle Projekte, die dazu stattgefunden haben, entwickelt wurden, haben sehr, sehr wichtige gesellschaftliche Herausforderungen sich angenommen und versucht, Lösungen dafür zu finden. Aber eine Sache, die waren alle total coole Kids. Ich bin ein großer Fan von dem Philipp, den ich den kleinen Professor nenne, der auch eine sehr, sehr coole Anwendung gebaut hatte. Der Vorteil von Frank Rieger, da hat sich ja danach eine total spannende Diskussion entwickelt. Und der meines Wissens 14-jährige Philipp, ich hoffe ich vertue mich nicht, saß im Publikum und hat dann auch ganz viele Fragen gestellt und wörtlich sein Zitat war, also seine Frage war, er fing an mit, ja, hallo Herr Rieger, ich weiß nicht, ob sie sich dran erinnern, aber es gab 2009 eine Folge Chaosradio, in der sie das und das gesagt haben. Also es war erstaunlich.
Chaosradio, das beste Bildungsprogramm, wo gibt?
Und er war damals 9, props an Philipp.
Allerdings.
Das ist eine super Anekdote und ich glaube, generell die Bühnensicherheit hat mich auch ziemlich gefleischt von den Jugendlichen. Sie haben am Sonntag nach zwei ziemlich durchzächten Nächten vor insgesamt 200 Menschen ihre Projekte vorgestellt. Auch mit allen Fehlern und Erfolgen, die man durchlebt, wenn man sich mit Software auseinandersetzt. Ich war generell beeindruckt, wie selbstbewusst diese Jugendlichen sprechen, also gar nicht, was ja auch immer wieder gesagt wird. Die sind so asozial oder nicht sozial kompatibel. Ich fand das komplette Gegenteil war der Fall. Ich fand die Jugendlichen waren auch sehr wach, was Fiona eben gesagt hat, was gesellschaftliche Herausforderungen angeht und haben ihre eigene Rolle auch total gut reflektiert. Am Ende einer Projektpräsentation hat ein Junge, weil dann die Zeit ablief, gesagt, wir wollen dieses Projekt auch kommerzialisieren. Dann waren Daniel und ich schon dabei, das abzumoderieren. Dann hat er sich noch mal das Mikro geben lassen, wo ich schon dachte, so walk on. Ich wollte noch mal sagen, ich war nervös, weil die Zeit abgelaufen ist. Aber selbstverständlich ist das ein Open Source Projekt. Wir glauben an Open Source. Wir finden das großartig, wenn Software offengelegt wird. Ich habe das einfach nur aus Stress gesagt. Der Junge war 15 und hat das beste Open Source Statement. Und hat gesagt, liegt auf GitHub. Das hat uns ziemlich beeindruckt.
Kurzer Anerklärung, GitHub sei eine Webseite, wo man Quellcode hinterlegen kann. So viel zu den beiden Projekten. Fiona, ich würde bei dir gerne noch wissen, du machst diesen Podcast, der auch für Anfänger, vielleicht zur Schaffung von Medienkompetenz dienen kann. Hast du den Eindruck, dass das dafür genutzt wird? Oder ist das so wie bei manchen dieser Sachen, dass es dann halt doch die Leute hören, die eh schon Bescheid wissen, um sich nochmal bestätigen zu lassen, dass sie Bescheid wissen?
Ja, du kennst das wahrscheinlich auch. Es gibt immer auch einen Anteil nostalgischer Hörer, auf jeden Fall, die denken, ach ja, cool, da wird nochmal ein Computer erklärt. Ich weiß allerdings, zum Glück habe ich auch einen relativ guten Resonanzraum, ich kriege auch viel Feedback. Das heißt, ich weiß auch, dass auch die noch was lernen. Aber nein, es gibt auch auf jeden Fall viele Leute, für die das ein sehr niedrigschwertiges Angebot ist, die sich vielleicht für Computer interessieren, aber überhaupt keinen technischen Background haben. Und muss ich auch nochmal sagen, davon gibt es echt viele. Und davon gibt es immer mehr, merklich, auch spätestens seit der Snowden-Affäre, wo Leute anfangen zu denken, ja, ich benutze diesen Computer, der bestimmt eigentlich maßgeblich meinen Tagesablauf und viele andere Aspekte meines Lebens und meines Alltags. Aber ich habe keine Ahnung, was da passiert. Ich würde es aber gerne lernen. Aber ja, deswegen ist es ja auch gut, wenn die die schwellige Angebote geschaffen werden. Und das bei dem Podcast auf jeden Fall so. Klar, ich freue mich immer über mehr Leute, die überhaupt keine Ahnung haben und den hören. Der ist auf jeden Fall auch für diese Zielgruppe zugeschnitten.
Ist das denn so, dass dann da Fragen beantwortet werden? Oder ist das dann auch so, dass du dann hinterher nochmal so, aber könntest du dann nochmal bitte erklären, dass?
Ja, selbstverständlich sollen Fragen beantwortet werden. Aber meine Aufgabe ist es dann halt immer zu denken, okay, er hat mir jetzt diese Antwort gegeben, wie hätte ich vor drei Jahren darauf reagiert? Wahrscheinlich gar nicht, ich hatte einfach genickt und gesagt, aha, ja, okay, alles klar, ciao. Aber mittlerweile versuche ich dann halt, mich in diese Lage hinein zu versetzen und nachzufragen, ja, hä, was ist denn das überhaupt?
Nee, ich meine sozusagen die Hörer, also wenn Leute, die frisch sind und das gehört haben, stellen die dann noch weitere Fragen an sich oder sind die dann zufrieden und wissen erst mal Bescheid und gehen dann?
Also ich kriege manchmal noch persönlich Nachfragen, dafür gibt es dann auch eine Kommentarfunktion, wo Leute sich nochmal äußern können, je nachdem, aber ich glaube, es ist auch nicht so wahnsinnig zielführend zu sagen, okay, wir schneiden ja dann so eine sehr, sehr allgemeine Frage an wie, was ist ein Internet oder was ist ein Computer und was ist überhaupt dieses Betriebssystem. Darauf wird man keine abschließende Antwort geben können, aber ich glaube, es ist sehr wichtig, sich damit generell mal auseinanderzusetzen. Ich glaube, auch so eine strategische Überforderung ab und zu ist gar nicht so doof. Dann hat man wenigstens ein paar Sachen mal gehört und die Synapses schließen sich halt später. Die Synapses schließen sich später.
Strategische Überforderung, das finde ich ein super Name.
Ich finde auch, aus meiner Sicht, ich habe mit dem ganzen Kram ja erst vor einer Weile angefangen. Ich glaube, das Schöne daran ist gar nicht so sehr, wenn man anfängt, sich mit Computern auseinanderzusetzen. Ich finde jetzt Antworten auf alle meine Fragen, sondern man entdeckt eigentlich erst ein großes, immer größer werdendes Universum voller neuer Fragen.
Oh mein Gott, also wenn ihr überhaupt damit anfangen wollt, dann seid euch gewahrt, dass ihr dann noch mehr Zeit investiert. So, jetzt haben wir euch ein paar Projekte vorgestellt. Wir machen gleich noch ein bisschen weiter hier im Chaos Radio im Domun auf Ritz. Vorher gibt es aber natürlich die Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr.
Diese Band ist gerade in aller Munde, weil die machen Bilderbuch im Kopf. Freitag, 20. März. Live im Astra in Friedrichshain.
Solange es noch Karten gibt. Gibt's Karten überall, wo's Karten gibt.
Und das hört man um kurz nach halb nein, um genau halb 12. Oh mein Gott.
Die Finanzierung der Flüchtlingshilfe ist zwischen Bund und Ländern weiter umstritten. Die Länder lehnen es ab, die Unterbringung von Flüchtlingen aus einem Fonds für die Fluthilfe zu zahlen. Das teilte Banenburgs Ministerpräsident Woidke nach einem Sondertreffen der Ministerpräsidenten der Länder mit. Ein weiteres Thema der Konferenz war die Zukunft des Solidaritätszuschlages. Alle Teilnehmer erklärten, dass das Geld aus dem Soli auch über 2019 hinaus gebraucht wird. Die von SPD und Grünen geführten Länder wollen den Soli in die Einkommenssteuer einbauen. Die Unionsministerpräsidenten fordern dagegen eine Sonderabgabe zur Unterstützung wirtschaftlich schwacher Regionen. In Berlin sollen Flüchtlinge willkommen geheißen werden. Das steht in einer Resolution, die alle Fraktionen heute im Abgeordnetenhaus verabschiedet haben. Verurteilt werden rechtsextreme Kampagnen gegen die Unterbringung von Menschen auf der Flucht. Sorgen von Anwohnern nehme man aber ernst, heißt es weiter. Hintergrund der Resolution sind die Proteste gegen die geplanten Containerdörfer für Flüchtlinge. In Griechenland haben erneut Zehntausende gegen die Sparpolitik der Regierung protestiert. Das öffentliche Leben war heute weitgehend lahmgelegt. Alle nationalen und internationalen Flüge fielen aus, ebenso Ferien und der öffentlichen Nahverkehr. Schulen blieben geschlossen, in den Krankenhäusern gab es nur eine Notversorgung. Griechenland hatte 2010 nur mit einem milliardenschweren Rettungskredit von EU und IWF vor dem Bankrott bewahrt werden können. Im Gegenzug verpflichtete es sich unter anderem, öffentliche Ausgaben zu reduzieren. Im Tarifkonflikt mit der Deutschen Bahn will die Eisenbahner Gewerkschaft EVG bis zum 12. Dezember auf Streiks verzichten. Man werde zunächst das umfangreiche Angebot der Bahn prüfen, teilte die EVG mit. In dem Tarifkonflikt streiten sich die EVG und die Gewerkschaft der Lokführer seit Monaten, wer für welche Berufsgruppe die Verhandlungen führen darf. Die Bahn hatte den beiden konkurrierenden Gewerkschaften vor einer Woche ein neues Angebot vorgelegt. Die GDL will morgen weiter darüber verhandeln. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen. In Berlin haben wir 1°C in Marzahn, 2°C sind es in Kreuzberg, Prenzlau 1°C, Cottbus-Küre 2°C und Ciesa 3°C. Bis auf minus 2°C geht es heute Nacht runter, es bleibt meist trocken. Und der morgige Freitag wird dann ähnlich wie heute. Bei 1 bis maximal 4°C gibt es einige harmlose Wolkenfelder und längere sonnige Phasen. Mit einer Meldung aus Brandenburg, Vorsicht auf der A10. Berliner Ring Richtung, äh, nee, 3° Potsdam Richtung 3° Haveland. Zwischen dem 3° Werder und Großkreuz da ist ein kaputter Lkw auf dem rechten Fahrstreifen.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RWB.
Und wenn ihr diesen Sound mögt, oder diesen Sound, dann hört doch mal den Fritz Soundgarden mit Schöckern. Immer dienstags ab 20 Uhr und im Radio. Oder jederzeit auf fritz.de Musik Streams.
Heute Chaosradio im Blumen auf Fritz, das heißt es sind ganz, ganz viele Leute im Studio, nämlich im einzelnen Fiona, Daniel, Maria, Leander und Seba. Salut und guten Abend. Sehr schön. Es geht heute um Medienkompetenzvermittlung, das heißt es geht darum, Menschen dazu zu bringen, sich mit diesem Technikkram auseinanderzusetzen, der unser Leben irgendwie durchzogen hat. Und wir haben festgestellt, es ist an der Schule schwierig, weil die Lehrer das irgendwie nicht können und weil es auch nicht genug Wissen und vielleicht auch Geld gibt. Es gibt so ein paar größere, mit Geld beworfenen Organisationen, wo man so ein bisschen fragen muss, aus welcher Motivation macht ihr das. Und es gibt hier von den Anwesen vorgestellte Projekte, wo man sagen kann, na, da ist vielleicht sozusagen alles irgendwie miteinander verbunden. Und ich wollte jetzt noch eine Frage stellen, weil ich das Gefühl habe, es gibt bei diesem Thema, also Medienkompetenz und Medienpädagogik, wo der Herr Seitz ja heute auch hier herkommt. Und wir kennen uns von, es gibt so Preisverleihung, es gibt so Medienpreise. Da machen halt dann Leute bis zur Altersgruppe XY irgendein Projekt, wo sie unter Beweis stellen, dass sie mit Medien schon umgehen können oder dass andere Menschen werden ausgezeichnet, weil sie halt genau das ermöglichen. Und ich habe das Gefühl, es gibt sozusagen so ein eigenes Subbiotop an Medienpädagogikunternehmen, könnte man fast sagen. Also da gibt es die GMK und ein Medienkulturzentrum und so ganz viele Vereine, die auch immer so einen schönen Namen haben. Und ich frage mich, warum ist das so? Das klingt so, als ob das sozusagen so ganz viele kleine, also wie so eine Art eigene Start-up-Szene, könnte man fast sagen. Also die existiert länger, aber so sagen halt kleine Firmen, die sich irgendwie alle mit demselben Thema beschäftigen. Dann fragt man sich, warum ist das nicht alles eine große Firma und die machen dann was Richtiges. Was ist da los?
Also Bildung ist immer in Deutschland divers und das denke ich total gut so, weil es gibt einfach verschiedenste Zugänge. Bildung ist Ländersache, deswegen verteilt sich das schon mal, hängt an verschiedensten Töpfen, die meisten Medienpädagogik. Institutionen, gemeinnützige Institutionen, Vereine ganz häufig werden durch Jugendtöpfe finanziert in den Ländern, manche durch Kulturtöpfe, aber meistens hängt das an so der Jugendförderung. Und da gibt es eine sehr bunte Landschaft und es gibt die GmK, die Gesellschaft für Medienpädagogik und Kommunikationskultur, das ist, wenn man so mag, der Chaos Computer Club für die Medienpädagogen. Das wird sie sich ja sehr freuen. Da finden viele Medienpädagogen quasi eine Vernetzung, eine Struktur vor, um gemeinsam Lobbyarbeit für Medienpädagogik zu machen, um gemeinsam Sachen zu diskutieren. Unser Kongress heißt Forum Kommunikationskultur, der hat gerade stattgefunden, in der Verein dann so 300-400 Menschen. Das sind unterschiedliche Dimensionen, hat 1000 Mitglieder, ich vermag nicht zu sagen, wie viele da quasi nicht organisiert sind, aber es gibt jetzt auch nicht unendlich viele Medienpädagogen in Deutschland. Um da nochmal kurz meine Ehre wieder herzustellen, Mediennutzung ist der vierte Begriff, den ich vorher nicht parat hatte, weil er halt wahrscheinlich einfach schon so selbstverständlich ist.
Wenn ihr nicht wisst, wovon Daniel gerade redet, dann müsst ihr euch den Podcast zu dieser Sendung anhören, er hat nämlich ganz am Anfang die vier Säulen der Medienkompetenz erklärt. Also er hat die drei erklärt, die eigentlich vier sein sollten. Und das ist jetzt die vierte.
Genau, und nachdem es eben nicht nur um Nutzung geht und wie Sebastian vorhin schon sagte, man das schon beobachten kann, dass man erstmal natürlich Medien stark nutzt, wollen wir eben auch fördern, dass sie kreativ selbst angewandt werden. Und deswegen gibt es auch viele Wettbewerbe, wo wir versuchen, das anzuregen, zu fördern, Kids auf eine Bühne stellen, ihnen eine Möglichkeit geben, ihre Lebenswelt darzustellen, ihre Produktion darzustellen. Da gibt es verschiedenste Medienwettbewerbe, die wirklich fantastisch darstellen, zu was Jugendliche in der Lage sind. Also es gibt ja genug Menschen, die an Jugend zweifeln. Die sollen sich gerne mal mb21.de zum Beispiel anschauen. Da kann man über die letzten 15, 16 Jahre beobachten, was Jugendliche alles aus Medien machen. Da könnten noch viel mehr Coding-Projekte zum Beispiel sein. Da gibt es ganz viel von Animation über Installation, über Medienkunst, da gibt es Webseiten, da gibt es YouTube-Channels. Da gibt es eine ganze Bandbreite, deckt wahrscheinlich noch nicht das ganze Medienhandel von Jugendlichen ab. Es gibt natürlich dann auch noch Filmwettbewerbe, Deutsche Jugend Videopreis und so verschiedene Geschichten, die alle gute Einblicke geben. Eben nicht nur das, was Jugendliche mit Medien tun, sondern auch welche Themen Jugendliche über Medien bearbeiten. Da sind wir wieder bei dem Punkt, dass es eben im Kern dann doch nicht um das einzelne Medium und das einzelne Stück Technik geht, sondern das, was wir daraus machen und was uns bewegt.
Ich hab immer das Gefühl, wenn man sich das ein bisschen anguckt, dass die Leute, an die es gehen soll, zumindest wenn sie ein Wettbewerb haben, dass sie auch aus einem kleineren Zirkel rekrutiert, als es eigentlich Potenzial hätte.
Ja, klar, es kann immer mehr sein, es deckt aber schon auch ein gutes Spektrum ab. Also bei MBR 20 reichen 1700 Kinder und Jugendliche Produktionen ein, also das ist jetzt auch nicht nichts. Aber natürlich gibt es viel mehr Jugendliche, die etwas tun und die muss man natürlich erst mal erreichen. Und da ist immer die Frage, wer da auch zusammenarbeitet. Also als Pädagogin hat man ja immer ein Ziel, auf das man hinarbeitet. Ich hatte dir das im Vorfeld schon gesagt, mein Ziel hier wäre jetzt nochmal auch quasi Allianzen zu prüfen. Und ich bin total davon überzeugt, dass der Chaos Computer Club und Medienpädagogik unglaublich gut zusammenpassen, weil wir auf vielen Ebenen gemeinsame Ziele verfolgen und jeweils etwas haben, was die anderen nicht haben. Also wir kommen gerade an technologische Grenzen, wo Medienpädagogen nicht mehr alles auf dem Schirm haben. Also wenn es Überwachungsthemen und so weiter. So als Generalist kennt man viele Medien als Medienpädagogen, aber eben dann auch nicht unbedingt eine Tiefe. Ich glaube, da bringt der Club sehr viel.
Wie dann die Strukturen im Hintergrund halt funktionieren, wo wir halt einfach den Bogen schlagen können und euch halt auch unterstützen können, wenn es um die technische Verständlichkeit geht, das halt für Jugendliche oder auch die Eltern aufzubereiten, dass dort halt das Verständnis geweckt wird.
Hey, kennt ihr euch eigentlich?
Ja, seit der Vorbereitung, ja.
Ja, deswegen sind wir ja hier.
Chaosradio bringt Herzen zusammen, sehr schön. Eine andere Frage, also das ist natürlich spannend, eine andere Frage, die ich auch noch stellen möchte, ist, wenn man sich diese Medienpädagogische Unternehmung anguckt, dann, also hab ich zumindest den Eindruck, zum Schluss hängt immer ein Bundesministerium oben dran. Also meistens das Bundesministerium für Familie, Senioren, Frauen und Jugend. Und auch ihr habt glaube ich irgendwann im Verlauf der Sendung gesagt, dass man so einen großen Geldgeber, dass das schon ganz cool wäre und das in der öffentlichen Stelle natürlich auch irgendwie nicht unwahrscheinlich, wenn es um sowas geht, ist denn Medienkompetenzförderung in Deutschland politisch beeinflusst? Also ist das dann irgendwie abhängig davon, wer jetzt irgendwie letzte Wahl gewonnen hat? Oder ist man sich da eigentlich so, ist das eines der wenigen Themen, wo man sich im Großen und Ganzen einig ist, ja, das muss mal so gemacht werden?
Also es gibt immer Strukturförderung und Projektförderung und die Strukturförderung wird mindestens nicht größer, in Teilen wird sie zurückgefahren.
Was ist Strukturförderung für die Leute, die das nicht kennen?
Strukturförderung heißt, dass man quasi, ohne immer wieder neu beantragen zu müssen, Mittel dauerhaft bekommt und damit kann man halt Stellen finanzieren, damit kann man Häuser erhalten, also es gibt in vielen Städten Medienzentren, wo Jugendliche eben hingehen können und mit Medien arbeiten und sowas ist ganz wichtig, um einfach so eine Kontinuität zu gewährleisten und nicht immer wieder Dinge komplett neu zu erfinden. Bei Projektförderung ist es eben so, da muss man tatsächlich...
Also die Strukturförderung ist sozusagen, also so egal, wer jetzt gerade irgendwer da macht, die bricht jetzt nicht irgendwie einen großen Geldtopf aus, aber die kommt zumindest stetig.
Genau und natürlich gibt es da Abstimmung, natürlich gibt es da einen gesellschaftlichen Diskurs, also es ist ja nicht so, dass Politik grundsätzlich mein Gegenüber ist, vor dem ich mich wehren muss, sondern da werden ja auch gesellschaftliche Themen ausgehandelt und das ist erst mal richtig so, aber die Frage ist natürlich immer, bin ich da sehr stark davon abhängig oder gibt es ein Stück weit eine Unabhängigkeit, wo ich eben auch mal Themen behandeln kann, die vielleicht gerade der Staat nicht unbedingt sehen will. Also komme ich wieder auf Überwachung zurück, also da werde ich wahrscheinlich gar nicht bei der Bundesregierung drei Millionen beanzahlen können, um das Thema anzuziehen. Insofern brauchen wir schon ein Stück weit Unabhängigkeit und die findet eben vor allem über dauerhafte Mittel statt und bundeszentrale für politische Bildung würde ich da jetzt noch neben das Bundesfamilienministerium stecken, die auch eben ganz starke Förderer von Medienpädagogik sind und auch quasi schon relativ unabhängig agieren, obwohl sie am Innenministerium hängen, das muss man an der Stelle auch immer wieder sehen, dass wir teilweise auch komische Strukturen haben, wo wir was gesellschaftlich andocken, dennoch schaffen die es auf jeden Fall so ihre Themen zu setzen und da Medienpädagogik zu fördern, wo es auch wichtig ist.
Also wir hatten die Strukturförderung, dann gibt es noch die Projektförderung, ist das da anders?
Also ganz vieles über das Familienministerium zum Beispiel, auch bundeszentrale gibt es einige längere fristige Projekte, aber das meiste sind tatsächlich Projektförderung und das hat aber vor allem damit zu tun, dass Bildung Länderaufsage ist, das heißt eigentlich dürfen die Bundesministerien nur Piloten fördern, also sie können quasi nur neue Themen anstoßen, aber die dauerhafte Förderung, die obliegt den Ländern.
Aber jetzt trotzdem noch zu eigentlichen Fragen zurückzukommen, ist das politisch gefärbt? Also welche Projekte da gefordert werden, also kann man das erkennen?
Kann man ganz klar erkennen, auf jeden Fall.
Man sieht das schon so, wenn man sich ein Stück weit mit dem Thema beschäftigt, dass da schon einige wirtschaftliche Interessen wirklich forciert werden.
Ja, und nicht nur wirtschaftliche Interessen, sondern ganz stark, das fällt auch Kinder- und Jugendmedienschutz, also so Safer Internet und wir laden Kinder dazu ein, eigene Schutz-Apps zu bauen und so, das ist quasi, das ist politisch en vogue und beißt sich, glaube ich, so ein bisschen mit den Projekten, die wir hier auch im Laufe der Sendung so gehört haben, wo es eigentlich eher darum geht, so die Chancen zu betonen und den eigenen Handlungsspielraum zu erweitern und nicht zu verengen, aber zudem, wie sehr man von so einem politischen Farbenwechsel abhängig ist. Ich weiß, dass im Bundesfamilienministerium, ich kann immer nur die Abkürzung und das nicht aussprechen, BMF, SFJ, du kannst das in Gänze. Na jedenfalls, dieses Familienministerium ist ja jetzt irgendwie auch schon seit einem Jahr konstituiert. Letztes Jahr war ja Bundestagswahl und in der Folge sortiert sich so ein Ministerium ja auch immer neu, wenn das gerade eine politische neue Führung bekommt und es gibt dort ein Referat, das heißt Digitales und Medien und wenn man auf das Organigramm von diesem Familienministerium guckt, steht da halt immer noch Endpunkt Endpunkt. Also es ist einfach immer noch nicht besetzt und das ist natürlich schon so ein Zeichen, dass du schon sehen kannst irgendwie vielleicht geht gerade von diesem Ministerium in diesem Bereich nicht der größte Impuls aus, weil wenn es wirklich wichtig wäre, dann hätte man sich darum gekümmert, dass da jemand schon mit Feuer ist und die Projekte die gut sind weiter vorantreibt.
Ja ich finde, es tauchen total viele Beispiele dafür auf, dass also ich fand halt vorhin immer den Aspekt interessant, dass jemand sagte, hey ja aber es ist total wichtig, dass es in der Schule gelehrt wird und dass man das da durchsetzt und das stimmt, dem stimmen wir ja alle zu, aber man kann halt echt nicht darauf warten und ich glaube keiner von uns geht ja hin und sagt allen Leuten, jetzt lernt alle programmieren, aber wir schaffen halt ein Angebot, das es sonst nicht gibt.
Das kann ich nur unterstützen, also ich glaube, das ist halt der Unterschied zu dem, zu dieser Forderung, das muss doch alles in der Schule sein, dass wir einfach schon mal machen. Und natürlich auch ein bisschen das Feld irgendwie.
Wir geben halt Impulse.
Ja, die Verantwortlichen zeigen auch ein Stück weit immer gegenseitig mit den Fingern auf dich. Einmal die Politik sagt oder die übergeordnete Politik sagt, ist Schulsache. Die Schule sagt, ist Elternsache. Die Eltern sagen, ist Schulsache. Das fühlt sich im Grunde genommen keiner verantwortlich für die nächste Generation die Verantwortung zu übernehmen und ein Stück weit anzuleiten, wo es langgeht.
Also müssen es halt Leute machen, die Bock drauf haben. Es ist jetzt auch kein ungewöhnlicher Hergang. Also, dass irgendwie Leute eben nicht aus dem politischen Bereich oder nicht aus dem schulischen Bereich und die generell nicht in Strukturen drin stecken, einfach sagen, jetzt machen wir mal und dann kann das ja im besten Fall rüber schwappen.
So Institutionen wie uns alle, die wir hier versammelt sind, gibt es ja im Grunde genommen nur, weil sich keiner die Verantwortung dafür übernehmen möchte und ich glaube, es würde uns alle sehr begeistern, wenn die Politik dort aktiver wäre und mehr Input liefern würde und mehr Aktivität auch zeigen würde, dass wir uns im Grunde genommen als überflüssig achten können. Das ist eigentlich das Ziel von allen hier am Tisch.
Und vielleicht nicht die 17. Initiative zu gründen, sondern einfach auf die Pferde zu setzen, die schon bewiesen haben, dass es funktioniert.
Na, wir werden sehen, ob das in Zukunft in Erfüllung tritt, ich glaube eher nicht, aber das ist möglicherweise nur meine persönliche Meinung. Und ich möchte zum Schluss noch zu einem ganz konkreten Beispiel kommen. Und zwar ist ja Apropos Chaosradio, Apropos Chaos Computer Club vom 27. bis 30. Dezember wieder der Chaos Communication Congress. Und auch da gibt es ein spezielles Programm für Leute, die noch nicht so doll alt sind. Und da kann Pat uns was genau darüber erzählen. Hallo und guten Abend.
Ja, hallo, hallo, in Studio.
Schönen guten Abend.
Und es gibt da einen sogenannten Junghackertag und du hast da mitgemacht?
Ja, nein.
Nein, ja, nein.
Der Junghackertag ist nicht mein Bereich.
Da kann ich aber dem Pat gerne noch ein paar Informationen zu liefern.
Genau, wir wollten ja Kontakt aufnehmen, hab ich schon gehört.
Jetzt bin ich verwirrt. Ich dachte, wir reden jetzt heute mit dir, damit du uns ein bisschen was über den Junghackertag erzählst.
Ja, ich hab letztes Jahr den Kidspace ins Leben gerufen und da geht's ja um Kinder unter 12, also für die Kleineren. Das geht dann schon so bei ein bis zwei Jahren los und da geht's dann um einmal darum, dass die Eltern und die Kinder eine Möglichkeit haben, ihre Kinder in den Kongress zu integrieren und nicht nur irgendwo abzugeben oder alleine hinzugehen. Und da lässt sich halt auch viel Wissen vermitteln. Das ist natürlich nicht ganz so pädagogisch wie mit den älteren Kindern. Wir machen eher so Sachen, dass wir da so, letztes Jahr hatten wir so einen Workshop mit Little Bits, das sind so kleine Platinen, die man aneinander klicken kann mit Magneten, die sich nicht verpolen lassen und so. Da kann man dann so kleine, ja kleine Geschichten draus bauen, die irgendwie Töne machen und leuchten oder mit Motoren und so weiter und so fort.
Oder ist das dann angenommen worden auch als, hey, das finde ich gut, dass es ihr angenommen worden ist, ja, ich kann meine Kinder hier abwerfen, schnell weg!
Ja, das war es. Also in Berlin war es früher so, dass es halt sehr eng war und wir hatten eigentlich nur so eine Lego-Ecke da und da gab es den Kids-Base halt noch nicht so richtig, da wurden wir viel mit Lego gespielt, auch von den Älteren. Dann gab es noch zwischendurch so einen Raum im Nebenhaus, wo man die Kinder abgeben konnte. Das hat mir jetzt nicht so gefallen, für meine Tochter. Da geht es mehr um Integration. Wir sind da ziemlich zentral eigentlich, direkt vor so einem Hauptsaal, Saal vor Saal 2, nicht vor Saal 1, und in den Foyers und haben da so einen ganzen Bereich, wo wir so ein eigenes Bällebad haben, also ein bisschen für Bewegung sorgen auch und so. Und das wird sehr gut angenommen von den Eltern. Die haben sich alle sehr gefreut, dass ihre Kinder da mitnehmen können und dass die da auch gut aufgehoben sind und auch so ein bisschen Einblick in den Kongress haben, weil das ja eine ganz interessante Szene ist für Kinder, die können halt unwiel sehen und ich persönlich bin Softwareentwickler und bin ganz froh, wenn ich meiner Tochter erklären kann, was ich so mache und das kann man halt nicht immer so gut sehen, aber auf dem Kongress sieht man das ganz gut, was man da mit so machen kann. Und da gibt es halt viele Punkte, die sich echt lohnen, also da die Kinder mitzunehmen. Meine Tochter hat auch einen riesen Spaß und kennt dann zwischen alle und so. Das macht echt, das ist schon ganz gut.
Okay, das ist sozusagen, das ist für die Unterzwölfigen und Leander, der ist ja 13, für den ist dann vielleicht der Jugendhackertag, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe.
Was ist das? Genau, der Jugendhackertag ist am Tag 3, wo Eltern mit ihren Kindern vorbeikommen können, wo ein Elternteil halt freien Eintritt erhält und die Kinder sowieso. Dort gibt es halt Projekte, wo Workshops stattfinden, wo gelötet werden kann, geschraubt werden kann, um ein bisschen so technische Fingerfertigkeiten zu schulen. Einfach vorbeikommen mit dem Kind, sagen wir würden gerne an dem Projekt teilnehmen und dann sofern Kapazitäten da sind, kann man das durchaus machen. Wir hatten im letzten Jahr 80 Jugendliche, die wir an einem Tag betreut haben, die halt gelötet haben. Es gibt so verschiedene Lötaktionen, wie den Penta-Bug, der angeboten wird, der von den Kids gelötet werden kann. Dann so eine kleine Anamalage, die halt mehr zum Schrauben gedacht ist, wo man Phasenprüfer braucht. Und in diesem Jahr wird es etwas Neues geben, wo ich jetzt noch nicht so viel zu verraten möchte, um auch noch die Spannung ein bisschen aufrechtlich zu erhalten.
Ah ja, das heißt, man soll auch wirklich dann zum Kongress kommen?
Ja, selbstverständlich. Also Hamburg ist eine Reise wert, aber der Kongresse ist sowieso eine Reise wert.
Na gut. Dann sehr schön. Pat, an dir auf jeden Fall vielen Dank und viel Spaß im Bällebad. Ich glaube ja, das ist auch eine von den Kindereinrichtungen, wo die Erwachsenen eigentlich das für sich selbst gemacht haben. Aber gut, so, das Chaosradio geht jetzt bald schon zu Ende. Wir haben noch ein paar Minuten und ich würde sagen, von jedem von euch noch sozusagen, wir es bei diesen großen, mit eben pädagogischen Kongressen auch mal schön gerne gemacht und ein Abschlussstatement haben. Was ist denn jetzt so mit der näheren Zukunft? Was wünscht ihr euch denn jetzt als Nächstes? Fangen wir mal ganz rechts an beim CeBAS.
Ich wünsche mir, dass unsere Projekte überflüssig werden, da die Politik halt die Notwendigkeit erkennt und endlich mal den Ball, den wir versuchen immer zurückzuspielen, aufnimmt und sinnvoll verwertet.
Und wie viel Hoffnung hast du, dass das klappt? Gut, wir belassen das so als Antwort.
Maria?
Ich habe gehofft, dass ich zuletzt erst sprechen muss.
Na gut, Fiona?
Ich hoffe mir schon mehr solcher Projekte, weil ich glaube, es lassen sich Dinge nicht einfach politisch oder mit viel Geld oder sonst wie lösen, sondern es müssen auch die richtigen Leute mit der richtigen Haltung machen. Und deswegen wünsche ich mir eher mehr Projekte, wie Chaos macht Schule, wie Jugend hackt und so weiter, weil Bedarf wird immer da sein, die Themen werden sich verändern, die sind glaube ich da nicht so entscheidend und ich wünsche mir, dass das Ganze nicht nur auf Probleme orientiert ist. Also es geht nicht darum permanent zu vermitteln, was man alles nicht darf und wie schlimm das alles ist, sondern am Ende geht es ein Stück weit um Technik-Faszination, aber es geht auch um die gesellschaftlichen Themen, die dahinterstehen und ich glaube so erreichen wir dann auch alle Jugendlichen, die das erreichen sollten.
Und ich wünsche mir, dass wir vielleicht morgen oder übermorgen einen Anruf aus dem Bildungsministerium bekommen, der sagt, ich habe von Jugendhack gehört im Chaosradio, das ist eine super Sache, wie machen wir das jetzt groß, weil scheiß drauf, dann redet ihr vielleicht auch über den Staatstrojaner und dass das nicht so geil ist, aber da können wir mit umgehen als souveräner Staat. Wir möchten, dass der Ansatz irgendwie vielen, vielen zugänglich wird.
Ja, ich wünsche mir, dass solche Projekte wie von uns oder andere auch strukturell etwas ändern, nämlich, dass sie Leuten die Angst nehmen davor, sich mit Technik auseinanderzusetzen, dass sie Leuten, die Menschen, die sich für Computer interessieren, auch eine Chance geben und viele, viele Möglichkeiten geben, ohne dass da noch Barrieren dazwischen sind. Ja, oder dass sie denken, sie können das ja gar nicht. Daran möchte ich gerne was ändern. Aber natürlich will ich vor allem, dass noch viel, viel mehr Leute das machen, gerne auch besser als wir alle zusammen. Wir wollen ja auch gar nicht arbeiten, wir geben das total gerne ab, wenn es da mehr Leute gibt, die das machen, super cool. Ihr seid alle Hörer und Hörerinnen, sind herzlich dazu aufgerufen und dritte strukturelle Änderung, dass alle Leute, die solche Fähigkeiten besitzen, Bescheid wissen, das auch gerne weitergeben.
So, große Wünsche könnt ihr gerne erfüllen. Ihr könnt einen Anfang machen für Leute, die sich da potenziell für interessieren können, eben den Podcast dieser Sendung weitergeben. Erscheint im Laufe der Nacht noch auf ritz.de, dann später auch irgendwann auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Außerdem soll ich noch sagen, wenn ihr euch für das Projekt Chaos macht Schule interessiert, es gibt an Berlin in jedem ersten Mittwoch des Monats im Chaos Computer Club Berlin ab 20 Uhr ein Treffen. In der Marienstraße 11 ist das. Und falls ihr euch generell für Themen interessiert und denkt, ja dieser Club, vielleicht könnte man da mal gucken, was sie so machen. So ganz vorsichtig. Dienstag und Donnerstag haben die Tag der offenen Tür. Mein Name ist Markus Richter, ich verabschiede mich jetzt auch. Bedanke mich nochmal bei Fiona, Daniel, Maria, Leander und Cebas. Wiedersehen.
Bitte schön.
Und übergebe dann einen Nightfight mit Flo Heiler, der euch, wenn ich es richtig sehe, so wie immer, mit Gitarrenmusik bewerfen wird, bis euch die Ohren bluten. Eine Sache bleibt mir noch zu sagen, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups. Tschüss!